here's the headline put pest animal
species on the pill don't call them says
scientist Humane alternatives to killing
rampant creatures such as wild boar deer
and gray squirrels are being developed
so you know these wild boar are huge
pests in a lot of the country especially
in like Texas so sometimes people
they'll just go out and say hey man hunt
as many of these damn things as you want
we just want to kill them there will be
people who will go up in helicopters and
just shoot these things from the sky
okay so what this scientist says is no
no don't go out there and kill them
that's kind of nasty and feels unethical
what you should do is just sterilize
them and then I thought okay so these
Masters of the Universe who want to
control the population that they
consider to be pests that the way that
they think is the cleverest without
arousing the ire of environmentalists
and humanitarians and all the like by
outright slaughtering them is they're
just going to put them on contraceptive
drugs but wait a second
aren't they doing that to us